[Music]
good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight a forklift driver made
the mistake of making fun of one of
America's most powerful people online
and for that thought crime the press and
Facebook teamed up to destroy him in a
moment the terrifying alliance between
elite media and woke capital it ought to
make you very concerned but first
tonight officially the Democratic Party
is led by people old enough to remember
the Korean War Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi but in reality power has shifted
the real leaders of the party today are
young pioneers radicals like
congresswoman Alexandria Cascio Cortes
they're the ones who determine the
agenda in the party for example six
months ago nobody had ever heard of the
green New Deal and now Joe Biden feels
obligated to mimic it today Biden
revealed his own climate plan like the
green New Deal it would put the entire
American economy in the hands of the
Democratic Party it would cost Biden
says about six point seven trillion
dollars how much is that well it's equal
to two full years of the entire federal
budget Biden says we must give Democrats
this power immediately or else the
entire planet will become uninhabitable
science tells us that how we act or
failed act in the next 12 years will
determine the very livability of our
planet so today I'm announcing my plan
for clean energy revolution it outlines
what we have to do to meet this
challenge the head-on
and how we're gonna get there we're
going to invest 1.7 trillion dollars in
securing our future so that by 2050 the
United States will be 100% clean energy
economy with net zero emissions just 12
years to act or the planet becomes
uninhabitable who thinks of these lines
actually we think we know it sounds
familiar maybe it's because Biden took
that line directly from the young
pioneer herself watch the world is going
to end in 12 years if we don't address
climate change like this is the war this
is our world war two like this is our
world war ii actually biden borrowed
more than just that wine the Daily
Caller News foundation discovered at
least five instances in which Joe
Biden's climate plan quotes left-wing
organizations either verbatim or very
closely
none of them are cited no quotation
marks and that's another benefit of
climate alarmism not only do you get to
seize absolute power over the country in
its economy you also get to ignore
federal copyright laws there isn't time